Pensiamo che i computer quantistici ci permetteranno di risolvere alcuni problemi più velocemente di quanto possiamo fare con i soli computer classici. Ma
capire come sia possibile è sottile. Oggi in Qiskit in the Classroom cercheremo di scoprire la fonte del potere del
calcolo quantistico esaminando uno dei primissimi
algoritmi. Benvenuto in Qiskit in the Classroom. In questa serie useremo Qiskit per esplorare alcuni concetti fondamentali
comunemente trattati nei corsi legati al calcolo quantistico. Ogni video è accompagnato da un modulo interattivo
linkato nella descrizione qui sotto. Quindi assicurati di darci un'occhiata. Se hai sentito parlare molto di computer quantistici, probabilmente hai
sentito che possono usare fenomeni quantistici come la sovrapposizione, l'entanglement e l'interferenza per risolvere
problemi in modi che i computer classici non possono. Ma come fanno esattamente queste caratteristiche ad aiutare? Nel 1985, David Deutsch è stato il
primo a dimostrare come ciò potesse accadere. Ha ideato quello che oggi viene chiamato algoritmo di Deutsch, in grado di risolvere un
problema in modo più efficiente di quanto potrebbe fare un algoritmo classico. Oggi daremo un'occhiata all'algoritmo di Deutsch e
a un'estensione successiva chiamata algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa, ed esamineremo come gli aspetti unicamente quantistici dei qubit
possano essere utilizzati a vantaggio dei computer quantistici. Poi eseguiremo questi algoritmi su un vero computer quantistico con Qiskit.
Esistono altri algoritmi quantistici che mostrano anche un vantaggio teorico rispetto ai noti algoritmi classici. E non tutti funzionano
con gli stessi principi di quelli che vedremo oggi. Quindi ciò che impareremo oggi non spiega in generale come funziona un computer quantistico,
ma ci aiuta a iniziare a capire come i principi della meccanica quantistica possano essere combinati per
creare un potente computer quantistico. Prima di immergerci nell'algoritmo di Deutsch, pensiamo prima a come i computer quantistici
siano diversi dai computer classici e come ciò potrebbe darci un vantaggio nella risoluzione di certi
problemi. Una differenza è che i bit quantistici chiamati qubit possono trovarsi in stati di sovrapposizione. Invece di essere
limitati allo stato zero o allo stato uno come un bit classico, un qubit
può trovarsi in uno stato di sovrapposizione di zero e uno. Scriviamo questo stato così,
dove a e b sono numeri complessi i cui quadrati sommano a uno, e più
qubit ci sono, più questo divario si estende. Due bit possono ancora essere in uno solo di questi
quattro possibili stati: 0 0, 1, 1 0 o 1
1. Due qubit possono essere in una sovrapposizione di tutti e quattro quegli stati classicamente ammessi, il che si
scrive così. In generale, un sistema classico di n bit può essere solo in uno dei 2 alla n possibili
combinazioni di zeri e uni. Un sistema quantistico di n qubit può essere in una sovrapposizione di tutti i 2 alla n di questi
stati. La scalabilità è esponenziale. Quindi anche se avessimo solo 10 qubit,
potrebbero essere in uno stato di sovrapposizione di 2 alla 10, ovvero 1.024 possibili combinazioni di zeri e
uni. La scalabilità esponenziale dello spazio degli stati dei qubit è chiamata
parallelismo quantistico ed è in parte responsabile del vantaggio dei computer quantistici rispetto a quelli classici. Ma un computer quantistico
non è solo un enorme processore parallelo. Il fatto che i qubit in un computer quantistico possano trovarsi in una
sovrapposizione di un numero esponenzialmente grande di stati non significa che abbiamo accesso a tutte le informazioni in ciascuno di questi
stati. Poiché la misurazione collassa il sistema in uno stato o nell'altro,
vediamo come si svolge in un problema semplice. Supponiamo che ci sia una macchina a cui
puoi fornire un singolo bit. Applicherà quindi una funzione al bit e ne restituirà un altro singolo. La macchina
è all'interno di una scatola nera a cui non possiamo accedere. Tutto ciò a cui abbiamo accesso è il bit
che le forniamo x e il bit che la scatola restituisce f
di x. Vogliamo scoprire qual è la funzione f che la macchina sta applicando.
Ci sono quattro possibili funzioni che portano un singolo bit a un altro singolo bit.
Quindi per scoprire qual è la funzione, possiamo semplicemente fornirle uno zero e vedere se restituisce uno zero o un uno, poi fornirle
un uno e fare lo stesso. Ognuno di questi due passi è chiamato una query. Questo
è un modo per confrontare algoritmi classici e quantistici attraverso il cosiddetto modello delle query, dove confrontiamo il numero
di query che ciascuno degli algoritmi deve fare alla scatola nera per risolvere il problema. Quindi in questo caso, il nostro
metodo classico ha dovuto interrogare la scatola due volte per conoscere la funzione. Vediamo se possiamo fare meglio se abbiamo un computer quantistico
che interroga la scatola nera. Invece di fornire prima uno zero e poi un uno,
il computer quantistico può fornire alla scatola un qubit in una sovrapposizione di zero e
uno. Quindi in effetti stiamo fornendo alla scatola entrambi gli input con una singola query. Allora
significa che possiamo conoscere la funzione con una sola query?
Purtroppo non è così. Capiamo perché questa idea fallisce quando la testiamo su un computer quantistico. Creeremo un
circuit con due qubit. Il qubit zero rappresentato qui da questa riga in alto sarà il nostro stato di input X che forniamo alla
scatola nera mostrata qui dal gate marrone etichettato UF. Il gate UF è
progettato per prendere il qubit zero come stato di input X, quindi applicare una trasformazione sul qubit uno che porta
lo stato zero allo stato f di x. Quindi finché il qubit 1 inizia nello stato
zero, l'output è x sul qubit 0 e f di x sul qubit 1. Quindi per trovare f di x per
entrambi x=0 e x=1 simultaneamente possiamo provare a mettere il qubit 0 in una sovrapposizione di 0 e 1 prima
di fornirlo alla scatola nera. Questo viene fatto con questo gate Hadamard rosso che trasforma lo stato zero in 1/√2
|0⟩ + |1⟩. Quindi dopo il gate della scatola nera, dovremmo ora avere una sovrapposizione di entrambi
f di 0 e f di 1 sul qubit 1. Quando misuriamo i due qubit, speriamo di
rispondere alla domanda: quale funzione c'è dentro la scatola nera? Usiamo il primitive sampler di Qiskit per eseguire il
circuit e restituire il risultato. Possiamo scegliere il numero di volte in cui il circuit viene eseguito, chiamato campioni, cambiando questo
parametro chiamato shots qui.
Questo equivale al numero di query che facciamo alla scatola nera. Vediamo se una sola query
funzionerà. Ecco il risultato. Abbiamo misurato il qubit 0 come zero. Quindi quello era
il valore di input x e il qubit 1 come 1, che era il valore di output f di x. Quindi ora
sappiamo che f di 0 è uguale a 1. Ma cosa dire di f di 1? Ecco dov'è il problema. Una volta
che abbiamo misurato lo stato, le sovrapposizioni sono collassate e siamo riusciti a misurare solo una parte della funzione con una
singola query. Questo non ci dice tutto ciò che dobbiamo sapere per determinare quale funzione sia. Avremmo bisogno di una
seconda query alla scatola per farlo. Quindi, anche se il principio del parallelismo quantistico ci permette di far valutare simultaneamente
alla scatola nera f di 0 e f di 1, non abbiamo accesso a entrambe
queste risposte. Il parallelismo quantistico da solo non è sufficiente. L'algoritmo di Deutsch
mostra come possiamo usare il parallelismo quantistico in modo leggermente diverso per imparare qualcosa sulla funzione dentro la scatola nera. Non saremo
in grado di capire esattamente qual è la funzione, ma saremo in grado di imparare qualcosa di nuovo su di essa con una
singola query che non potremmo fare con un computer classico. Iniziamo guardando una tabella delle quattro possibili
funzioni che portano un singolo bit a un altro singolo bit. Qui puoi vedere che due delle funzioni f_sub_1 e f_sub_4 restituiscono sempre
un singolo valore indipendentemente dallo stato di input. Chiamiamo queste due funzioni
costanti. f_sub_2 e f_sub_3 restituiranno zero o uno a seconda di
dello stato di x. Chiamiamo queste due funzioni bilanciate. L'algoritmo di Deutsch
determina se la funzione è costante o bilanciata apportando alcune modifiche intelligenti al circuit che abbiamo usato
prima. Ecco il circuit. Inizia preparando il qubit 0 nello stato 1/√2
|0⟩ + |1⟩ con un Hadamard come prima e il qubit 1 nello stato 1/√2 |0⟩ - |1⟩
con un gate NOT seguito da un Hadamard.
Quindi lo stato completo a questo punto è dove questo è lo stato del qubit 0 e
questo è lo stato del qubit 1. Preparare il qubit 1 in questo modo piuttosto che semplicemente
lasciarlo nello stato zero consente all'algoritmo di usare il parallelismo quantistico in combinazione con l'interferenza per imparare
sulla funzione della scatola nera. Vediamo cosa succede quando i qubit vengono immessi in UF, il gate della scatola nera: possono accadere alcune cose.
Se la funzione è costante, allora la scatola nera eseguirà alcune operazioni sul qubit uno soltanto, indipendentemente
dallo stato di zero. In questo caso, poiché UF non tocca il qubit zero e
non tiene conto del suo stato, il secondo Hadamard qui annulla semplicemente ciò che
il primo Hadamard ha fatto. E misureremo il qubit nello stato zero. Guardiamo la funzione bilanciata f_sub_2 come esempio per vedere
cosa fa UF allo stato in questo caso. Quando x è zero, f di x è zero e quando x
è 1, f di x è 1. Ricorda quello che ti ho detto sul gate UF. Prende il qubit 0
come nostro stato di input x e restituisce f di x sul qubit 1, assumendo che il qubit 1
sia partito nello stato zero. Quindi per questa funzione, ciò che UF fa al qubit 1 dipende
dal qubit 0. Se 0 è zero allora il qubit 1 sarà lasciato nello stato zero per ottenere f
di x = 0. Se il qubit 0 è 1, la scatola nera applicherà un gate NOT al qubit 1 e lo metterà
nello stato uno. Quindi otteniamo f di 1 uguale a 1. Questo è esattamente ciò che fa un gate CNOT, o controlled-NOT. Un
gate CNOT prende due qubit, un qubit di controllo e un qubit target, e capovolge lo
stato del qubit target se il qubit di controllo è nello stato uno. Ma non fa nulla al target se il controllo
è nello stato zero. Quindi UF per F2 è solo un CNOT su Q0 e Q1. Il gate
CNOT non farà nulla al primo termine poiché il qubit di controllo è nello stato zero. Ma sul secondo termine, questo
zero si capovolge a uno e questo uno si capovolge a zero. E se estraiamo un segno meno, vedremo che lo stato del qubit 1 è
invariato. Ma questo termine ha acquisito un segno meno. Quindi lo stato del qubit 0 è
in realtà quello che è cambiato. È passato dall'essere |0⟩ + |1⟩ all'essere |0⟩ meno
|1⟩. Quando applichiamo il Hadamard finale al qubit 0, questo lo trasforma nello stato 1. Quindi se la funzione nella scatola nera
è f_sub_2, misureremo un uno invece di uno zero. Si scopre che il gate UF per l'altra funzione bilanciata f3 è lo
stesso gate CNOT seguito da un NOT sul qubit 1. Quel NOT finale non influisce sul qubit zero. Quindi quando la funzione
è bilanciata, misureremo il qubit 0 nello stato uno alla fine del circuit. Ora, se non hai seguito tutto
questo, va bene. Ti suggerisco di lavorarci da solo per vedere come funziona. Il punto principale qui è ciò che
è successo quando abbiamo applicato il CNOT per le due funzioni bilanciate. Il qubit 0 è stato usato solo come qubit di controllo per cambiare
lo stato del qubit 1. Intuitivamente, potresti pensare che il qubit 0 rimarrebbe invariato. Eppure, in qualche modo le nostre
operazioni sul qubit uno hanno effettivamente cambiato lo stato del qubit zero modificando la fase relativa tra le due parti della
sua sovrapposizione. Questo fenomeno è noto come meccanismo del phase kickback ed è
estremamente controintuitivo come molti fenomeni quantistici. In un certo senso, puoi pensare al meccanismo del phase kickback
come al remare su una barca. L'atto di spingere l'acqua all'indietro ti propelle effettivamente in avanti. Proprio come le operazioni sul
qubit 1 cambiano effettivamente il qubit zero. Ora possiamo eseguire l'algoritmo di Deutsch su
Qiskit. Qui possiamo selezionare quale funzione mettere dentro la scatola nera, che abbiamo scelto essere F3. Ecco il
diagramma del circuit dell'algoritmo e possiamo eseguirlo come prima con il primitive sampler. Imposteremo il numero di
campioni a uno solo e vedremo cosa misuriamo. In questo caso, abbiamo misurato uno.
Quindi sappiamo che la funzione era bilanciata, il che è effettivamente quello che ci aspettavamo poiché la scatola nera conteneva la funzione f3. Quindi, con una sola
query, siamo stati in grado di differenziare tra queste due classi di funzioni.
Questo avrebbe richiesto a un algoritmo classico due query per determinarlo. Questo mostra un modesto vantaggio del calcolo
quantistico rispetto al calcolo classico, ma non è molto impressionante. Solo uno contro due. Ma l'algoritmo di Deutsch
è ancora estremamente importante nella storia del calcolo quantistico perché ha fornito la scintilla che ha portato altri
a pensare ad algoritmi quantistici più grandi e sofisticati.
Questo include un'estensione multi-qubit dell'algoritmo di Deutsch che dimostra un vantaggio quantistico molto più impressionante.
Si chiama algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa. Risolve un problema simile, ma in questo caso la funzione della scatola nera
che vogliamo conoscere prende n bit come input e restituisce un singolo bit. Come
prima, ci viene promesso che la funzione è costante, cioè il bit di output è sempre uno o sempre zero,
indipendentemente dalla stringa di bit di input, oppure bilanciata, cioè l'output è zero per
metà delle stringhe di bit di input e uno per l'altra metà. Esistono, ovviamente, altre
funzioni che portano n bit a un singolo bit che non sono né costanti né bilanciate. Ma in questo problema, ci viene
promesso che nessuna di queste funzioni è dentro la scatola nera. Quella nella scatola è garantita essere costante
o bilanciata. Il circuit di Deutsch-Jozsa è simile all'algoritmo di Deutsch, ma con più qubit. Qui abbiamo un'
implementazione dell'algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa per conoscere una funzione a tre bit. Questa volta abbiamo tre qubit
per lo stato di input invece di uno solo. E poi abbiamo quest'ultimo qubit per lo stato di output. Come prima,
prepariamo tutti i qubit di input nello stato |0⟩ + |1⟩ e il qubit di output
nello stato |0⟩ - |1⟩. Poi, anche se la matematica è un po' più complicata da seguire, il principio
rimane lo stesso. Se la funzione è costante, non dipenderà dai tre qubit in alto. Quindi i loro stati
si trasformeranno di nuovo a zero dopo i secondi Hadamard e la nostra misura darà una stringa di tre bit di tutti
zeri. Ma se la funzione è bilanciata, quando misuriamo i qubit dopo gli Hadamard, il phase kickback
farà sì che uno o più di quei bit siano uno. Potrebbe non essere così facile da vedere questa volta, ma se lavori
attraverso ogni passo da solo vedrai presto che deve essere così. Un modo per verificarlo è provare a calcolare la
probabilità di misurare tutti zeri con una funzione bilanciata. Dovresti ottenere una probabilità di zero. Eseguiamo l'
algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa su un computer quantistico con Qiskit. Il passo più difficile è probabilmente creare la funzione di Deutsch-Jozsa
che sarà la nostra scatola nera che interroghiamo qui. Questo codice produce una funzione di Deutsch-Jozsa casuale che è
garantita essere bilanciata o costante. Poi creiamo il nostro circuit di Deutsch-Jozsa inserendo la nostra scatola nera
qui. Di nuovo, eseguiamo il circuit con sampler e dopo aver misurato, guardiamo
i bit misurati per determinare se la funzione era bilanciata o costante.
Se sono tutti zero, è costante. Ma se c'è almeno un bit uno nella stringa, allora è bilanciata. In questo
caso otteniamo una stringa di bit 1 uno uno.
Quindi sappiamo che la funzione era bilanciata. Spero di averti dato il tuo primo sguardo su come gli algoritmi quantistici
possano sfruttare fenomeni quantistici interessanti e spesso sottili per ottenere il loro vantaggio rispetto ai
algoritmi classici. Probabilmente hai anche notato quanto possa essere complicato progettare algoritmi quantistici. Anche il primissimo
ha richiesto molta creatività per ottenere solo una modesta vittoria sui metodi classici. E da quel primo algoritmo,
fisici e informatici hanno continuato a trovare modi incredibilmente inventivi di usare la meccanica quantistica
a proprio vantaggio, incluse ulteriori estensioni e applicazioni dell'algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa. Se vuoi
saperne di più, e provare gli algoritmi di Deutsch e Deutsch-Jozsa per te stesso, vai al
modulo linkato nella descrizione per iniziare. Grazie per aver guardato e ci vediamo la prossima volta.